[Music]
a new more contagious variant of the
coronavirus
could be behind a more serious second
wave in south africa
b1351 could also be the first mutation
to beat an existing vaccine
a small study shows the astrazeneca
inoculation
only offers limited protection against
mild versions of the variant
and that's the vaccine much of africa
was banking on
well in a moment we'll talk to a
virologist involved in that astrazeneca
study
and put this into context but first
let's look at some of the other factors
driving case numbers in south africa
super spreader events and lockdown
fatigue are also being blamed
as the developed world gathers momentum
in vaccinating its populations
south africa is fighting a coronavirus
mutation south africa has just come out
of its second wave of coronavirus
infections within the last period of
2020
and us as a research institute are very
concerned that this may or may not be
related to the new strain of coronavirus
infections which has been found within
the country
the variant has been associated with a
higher viral load in infected people
making it more transmissible and leading
to sharp spikes in
infections south africa recorded over 15
000
coveted deaths in the last month and its
hospitals were filled to capacity
so we have had an unexpectedly
strong second wave in south africa it
came earlier than we'd anticipated and
it was much steeper in terms of numbers
there were two reasons for this one was
we think mass gatherings
before the christmas period there were
young people getting together
but also that we hadn't really
controlled the numbers of people for
example at funerals
so mass gatherings drove this partly but
that coincided with the emergence of the
new variant
which has indeed increased transmission
from one person to another so two things
concurred at the same time
this seems to be confirmed by
researchers on the ground
we find that participants particularly
in our research setting
have not been compliant to
non-pharmaceutical interventions they've
been non-compliant to traveling
restrictions
particularly across provinces they've
also been non-compliant to
self-isolation after testing positive
as well as attending parties
adherence to personal protection
measures are also slipping
like in mabonen an inner city cultural
hub in johannesburg
i'm having some hot water and honey and
ginger
and when i do drink it and i spill it
makes the mask wet
so that's why i remove the mask but
other than drinking the water and
singing it's on
[Music]
locals are beginning to tire of some of
the world's strictest lockdown measures
and skepticism is taking hold
there's no corona dog that doesn't exist
it doesn't exist they basically trying
to [ __ ] with our minds you know
while struggling entrepreneurs are
taking risks in order to survive
it's very difficult to adhere to the
rules of social distancing
and wearing masks fully so that's a bit
of a challenge but you know as a you
know restaurant owner
you know i don't want to chase the last
little client that i have so i'll do all
that i can just to try and keep
and keep you know keep the shop open
exactly what role the recently
discovered variant is playing in local
infection rates
remains to be seen
we are not particularly sure about what
this this coronavirus infection strain
will do in terms of the medication and
the vaccines we have thus far developed
we are hoping to have some very exciting
information in the next few weeks which
will answer some of those questions
and give us some more guidance around
this particular issue
but until scientists can be sure south
africa needs to remain
cautious as vaccine rollout has only
just begun
new variants and the efficacy of
vaccines let's talk about that with
neurologist penny moore she joins us
from wits university and the national
institute for communicable diseases
and contributed to the laboratory aspect
of this south african study
on the astrazeneca vaccine penny what's
the main takeaway from this study
the main takeaway unfortunately is that
the astrazeneca vaccine
which was tested in a relatively small
trial in south africa shows
virtually no efficacy against the
variant that was described in south
africa
and for that reason the south african
government has temporarily suspended
roll out of that vaccine in south africa
how much of
this is a blow or how much of a blow is
this to the country's efforts to combat
the pandemic considering it is just a
small study you said
it is a blur in the sense that this is
the vaccine that has
arrived in south africa we have um
access to stocks of the vaccine in south
africa and the rollout was literally
expected to begin any day
however it's not the only vaccine and
recent data from two other trials has
shown some efficacy against the south
african variant
and so the hope is that we'll be able to
rapidly roll out
other vaccines to combat covet 19 in
south africa
but this new variant is the one that's
spread among what 90 percent of the
population and
and a lot of young people i believe
well it's the dominant variant across
across our country now you know it was
first detected
in late october um and since then it has
swept across our country
um it is now as you said the dominant
variant in in every province in south
africa
and it's now moved beyond south africa
despite a fairly strict lockdown and has
been detected in several other countries
across the world
so many african countries have young
populations so
i guess this is quite a concern if this
is the variant that's going to spread
across africa
well you know it happens to have
infected many young people in south
africa but
um that is a consequence of our
demographics rather than of the virus
um i suspect if this virus was um
detected and it will be detected and has
been detected elsewhere
it'll track the epidemic that has been
observed with most of the other variants
across the world
how how likely is this going to become
the most dominant uh variant worldwide
do you think
yeah i mean viruses don't respect
borders as you can imagine
um there has been a concerted effort to
keep the south african variant out of
other countries
um but people do travel and the variant
as i mentioned has been detected
elsewhere
um it's not just a case of worrying
about this particular variant um
i think it's a it's a broader problem
that we need to be aware of this the
same set of mutations that define the
south african variant
have been very much detected in other in
other variants across the world
including now in brazil
and in the uk and so it's it's not just
the south african variant
it's a it's a more general case of the
virus evolving to become
uh better at dealing with our immune
response so
it's not it's not a case of worrying
about south african variants it's a case
of worrying about
evolution of this virus generally so
what are you saying that it's mutating
to the same pattern basically
yes that's correct yeah so essentially
what happens is that
is that people have a very similar
immune response to this virus and
whether you look at an immune response
and somebody infected with this virus
in the uk or in brazil in south africa
or in the u.s
people's immune response see the virus
in a very similar way and for that
reason the virus chooses very similar
ways to escape from the immune response
it's it's an ongoing
cat and mouse gain that all viruses
engage in with in response to host
host antibodies and t cells
but just clarify that for me is it is it
a case of
um is it just chance that that it
mutates in that same pattern or
or is there some sort of communication
between these viruses
no there's no communication between the
viruses but
viruses are targeted by the immune
system in very much the same way so
so there is a certain part of the virus
called the receptor binding domain that
is
the main part of the virus that is seen
by the immune system
and that is the main target and
therefore the virus tries its very best
to
to mutate away from antibodies that
target that site
it happens to be targeted equivalently
across the world and there's a single
or three mutations for example that
enable the virus to very rapidly get
away from those antibodies
and so it's it's converging to the same
way of getting away from
from a very conserved immune response
that all humans seem to have to this
virus
so penny at the end of the day what's it
mean for astrazeneca and it's vaccine
well estrogen estrogenically like all
the vaccine manufacturers are rapidly
tailoring their vaccine to be able to
deal with this variant
and to deal with other variants that are
emerging that have the same mutations
um the next question of course will be
what happens after that
this is a virus that's going to continue
to mutate and
this is not a once off event we've seen
it before even with sales kirby 2 we
will see it again
and so the question is how do we deal
with that on an ongoing
and continuous basis um we will now
watch the major manufacturers tailor
their vaccines
and then we'll have to see what happens
after that i suspect this will turn into
a very similar scenario to what happens
with the influenza vaccines where we
receive
a new and slightly different vaccine
every year to combat that virus
i suspect we will do the same for south
korea too in the future
but in this case not only could this be
the first vaccine that's been
made ineffective by the corona virus
it's it's also
not proving effective against older
people in other countries and then
young populations in africa
i think there is there is a there are
benefits and
and disadvantages to every vaccine
astrazeneca is a very cost-effective
vaccine
vaccine
and many of the other vaccines may have
for example higher levels of efficacy in
some groups but are much harder to roll
out into some populations
when we think about vaccines for for
south africa and for any country we are
balancing all of those things together
we're balancing
efficacy in various populations we're
balancing coverage
how easily can we roll a vaccine out
across across an entire country to
achieve some level of herd protection
that may be harder now
than we had predicted before but you
know all vaccines come with pros and
cons
we've seen we've seen other vaccines
also losing efficacy
against the south african variant and i
suspect we'll see the same for the
variant that is now coming out of brazil
um but as we
as we change all of these vaccines we
will continue to see
an ongoing trade-off in in benefits and
and disadvantages for each vaccine that
we'll need to consider carefully
and sorry to be such a pessimist but
this vaccine is the one that was brought
up big by by kovacs to distribute it to
poorer countries
um i guess that's yet another setback
for um
for south africa and the region
so a major thing to remember with this
trial um is that it failed to protect
against
um mild and moderate disease what we
don't know is whether this vaccine is
able to protect from severe disease
and for many people rolling out a
vaccine across any country
prevention of severe disease preventing
people from dying
is actually the main thing we want to
achieve and we don't know yet
whether the astrazeneca vaccine can do
that and the reason is that we
this vaccine was tested in a group of
people who with an average age of around
about 30
and they tend not to experience severe
disease so we need to find out whether
the estrogenic
vaccine does protect against severe
disease and there's good reason to think
it might
it uses a very similar platform to the
johnson johnson vaccine
and again this is a non-replicating
adenoviral
vaccine and that vaccine the johnson
johnson vaccine did protect
very effectively against severe disease
so i think there's still a lot we need
to learn about the estrogenic vaccine
there's a lot we need to learn about all
of these vaccines we cannot
extrapolate anything in my opinion from
one vaccine to another we need to test
in all situations neurologist penny
moore thank you very much for joining us
today
thank you time now for your questions
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
as the sars cov2 virus inevitably
continues to mutate
could it also mutate to become less
deadly
this is complicated but here goes um the
short answer is
yes that could happen and and we hope it
will
but there's no guarantee um scientists
used to believe
that pathogens always evolved to grow
less deadly because it was thought a
deadly disease
is an ineffective disease the reasoning
was
that if a pathogen kills its host
especially if it kills that host quickly
then it lowers its own chances of being
passed on so
less deadly more transmissible variants
should have an evolutionary advantage
right
well the problem with that logic is that
virulence can also be viewed as an
advantage because
the sicker the host grows the more
likely they are
to give their pathogen to someone else
since they're shedding more of it
some so we actually think there's kind
of a an evolutionary
trade-off between transmissibility
and virulence and and there are
certainly pathogens for instance
the tuberculosis bacterium that have
been infecting humans
for thousands of years yet still kill
large numbers of people to see what the
future
might hold for covet 19 therefore
scientists have been looking
at the other coronaviruses known to
infect
humans in particular the four that we
think have been doing it
for quite a while um they only cause
mild cold like symptoms interestingly
that might have less to do with them and
more to do with
us especially with our children one
theory
is that repeated exposure to those other
coronaviruses
in early childhood might be helping to
prevent
more severe cases of the sicknesses they
could cause
later in life if soros co2
does become an endemic background
illness
in our societies then then later
generations of children
will be exposed to it early at an age
when it rarely makes you seriously ill
and and that in turn
should make subsequent exposures much
less dangerous
or at least that's the hope
you